Speaker 1: Let's talk about the Florida miracle.
Anybody know what that is? No, I don't. This is a
really funny clip. And this is all part of Fox
News helping Ron DeSantis, even though he has
not declared yet that he is running for president.
Fox News is helping create the image that Florida
is a miraculous state. Now, I don't actually know
what the miracle is, but here is Maria BARTIROMO.
Quite a prominent Trump brown noser. But remember,
everybody on the right is realizing DeSantis might
have power here. Let's at least get on his
good side. Here is Maria BARTIROMO helping
Ron DeSantis promote the Florida miracle. Let's
see if we can figure out what that miracle is.
Speaker 3: Talk to us about the Florida miracle
and what you see happening for the country if,
in fact, it takes on this item. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Well, I think as you know,
because I come on your show, I mean, we were
getting hammered by the left, by the corporate
press, by bureaucrats like Fauci every step of the
way during COVID, whether it was businesses being
open, people working, having activities, kids
being in school. And, you know, I really took
a lot of incoming even a lot of my supporters
are telling me, man, you're getting killed.
You're really going to be put out to pasture here
politically unless you do something different. But
I just had to look and say, you know what, my job
as a leader is to put the interests of the people
I represent and their jobs over my own interests
and keeping my own job. And so if there's short
term political pain and ultimately if it doesn't
work out for me politically, that's fine. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I guess the miracle that Maria is
talking about, based on on Desantis's response,
is that in the middle of the pandemic, DeSantis
opened some sporting events, including wrestling
and UFC, and passed the Don't Say gay bill. Right.
I mean, like what? What's the Florida miracle that
they're talking about now? I will I will be very
upfront. I think Florida's great. And I spent
quite a bit of time in Florida, particularly in
those liberal counties down on the tip there as as
people refer to it. But the weather is great. The
food scene is great. I love the people. There's
a big Argentinean community there. There's a big
Jewish community there in southern Florida. That's
all great. But the truth is that if you zoom out
and look at the entire state, Florida's a pretty
damn mediocre state. And what I mean by that is
it's not a particularly great state by any metric,
and it's not a particularly terrible state by any
metric. But calling it a miracle is weird. Health
care is ranked 25th in Florida. All right. It's
right in the middle. Infrastructure is ranked 20th
in Florida. Crime is ranked 26th in affordability.
Florida is 33rd. There's overall pretty good
quality of life. If you have money in Florida and
also if you don't, a lot of the metrics really
are lacking like it. It's just unremarkable. There
is no big Florida story other than the mediocrity
that is the state of Florida Saw DeSantis put
kids back in school faster than some other states,
opened sporting events with audiences
during COVID, faster than some other states.
Some people liked it, some people didn't like it.
But that's it. They're turning what is a complete
non-story into a, quote, miracle, according to
Maria BARTIROMO. And it's because it's not about
the facts. It's about narrative. And the idea of
the narrative that's being created is one that
actually distinguishes DeSantis from Trump. And
remember, this is a big thing where Nikki Haley
is asked to distinguish herself from Trump. She
doesn't say anything other than I'm younger,
I'm a woman, and I'm Indian. That's how she's
playing identity politics. DeSantis Even though,
again on policy, he's almost identical to
Trump. He is also trying to create some
difference. And part of that now is I bucked what
was happening federally on COVID. And opened up
sporting events and sent kids back to school
earlier. Is that going to convince Republican
voters? I don't know. I'm not one of them, but I
guess we'll have to wait and see. This clip and
others from today. Find them on my Instagram
by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.